[Música]
florián antoine noemí juliette no son
estudiantes sino pasantes porque en la
escuela de moda alternativa y gratuita
casa 93 no hay alumnos no hay tampoco
profesor ni calificaciones la escuela
nació en 2005 en las favelas de río
donde ha permitido a jóvenes presos y
prostitutas salir del gueto instalada en
los suburbios de parís desde 2017 casa
93 tiene como objetivo ayudar a aprender
a vivir y el método funciona la escuela
fomenta el trabajo en grupo dirigido por
profesionales del sector y no en vano
las mentes creativas de ingenieras de la
cuarta promoción crearon colectivamente
una colección para llevar a cabo su
proyecto tuvieron que aprender a dominar
sus diferencias y sus egos i know y
inaudito la película que hicieron sobre
su colección muestra la diversidad como
algo natural normal e instintivo
así que la colección indie cuenta la
historia de bueno es nuestra historia es
la historia de la gente que se siente
diferente y no tiene miedo de mostrar su
singularidad de leyenda
cuando yo llegué a casa 93 sabía que
íbamos a trabajar en grupo aunque estaba
acostumbrado a trabajar solas me di
cuenta de que era muy importante poder
contar con los demás y saber compartir
las tareas escuchar ser escuchado y
poder compartir todo el tiempo
hasta ese punto
vengo del 77 en sena y marne de un
pequeño pueblo lo hace muy bien que
decir es el campo
hablando de mi caso creo que desde que
estoy en la casa
he evolucionado en cuanto a la ropa de
forma bastante significativa
porque antes solo me ponía las cosas más
sencillas posibles ahora estoy saliendo
un poco de mi zona de confort más
me pongo cosas que me hacen feliz y ya
no me importa como me tiran los demás
creo que cuenta mi historia
al igual que la de bastantes personas de
la clase que han crecido tanto física
como mentalmente
simón con montarme
sistemas ha tratado en su obra
en esta colección hemos tratado la
noción del extranet
de cuestionar la noción de normalidad
que como son percibidos por los demás
como
como lo ha traducido en su colección
es una colección que parte de una
historia que está en la película es una
evolución de un montón de personajes que
pueden ser percibidos como extraños y un
personaje principal que entra en este
universo y se cuestiona sobre
así que es muy extraño
un ser extraño es aquel que no es como
los demás y que quizás es más el mismo
que los demás
intente expresar mi creatividad de
tratando de ir más allá de estar fuera
de los códigos salir de las normas que
tenemos todos los días si intenté yo más
allá pero en cualquier caso nuestro
trabajo era mezclar
es decir yo no tenía una idea yo hice la
prenda y
mezclamos todas nuestras inspiraciones
todos nuestros deseos yo trabajaba sobre
las ideas de los demás y viceversa al
final surgió de forma bastante natural y
es una mezcla de todos nuestros deseos
de todas las emociones que teníamos en
ese momento esto es el fruto de eso
por eso
no tiene un enfoque comercial
no no creo después obviamente bueno al
menos para nosotros para nuestra
colección el objetivo no era vender así
que es cierto que era más fácil dejarnos
llevar es que hay que crear hace lo que
queríamos y poder permitir
creo que cuando algo no está en una
empresa en la que técnicamente en la
forma en que ganar dinero es más difícil
atreverse a hacer tantas cosas pero creo
que los que han triunfado se han
convertido en grandes empresas también
personas
han ido el riesgo de no ganar dinero con
ello
para la producción de la película los
alumnos trabajaron con una agencia de
dirección artística duro badass en los
años 90 un varas era un tipo duro
desde el año 2001 hadas es una mujer
fuerte y valiente
es muy poderoso lograr darles la voz a
estos estudiantes a estos jóvenes hay
mucho que decir que tienen una magnífica
creatividad hay un gran terremoto en el
mundo de la moda especialmente en estos
temas de diversidad
de la moda de hecho está empezando por
fin a aprender tenemos mucho sesión no
queda mucho camino por recorrer pero en
esta diversidad está ahí y se siente
bien de hecho realmente es expertos para
pensar
estamos avanzando estamos hablando de
belleza estamos hablando de plasma
estamos hablando de creatividad estamos
hablando de expresión artística para el
humano
y de hecho es el ser humano por encima
de todo y la creación de hecho eso es lo
que hay que promover me siento realmente
híper optimista de que esto tiene que ir
un poco más rápido pero va por buen
camino
una sola lengua
fruto de una colaboración bien pensada
la colección colectiva 2021 de casa 93
se presentó en unos grandes almacenes
parisinos para que el público se
familiarice por fin con los enfoques
alternativos